[Musique]
eh bien oui je suis une femme
et j'ose me présenter comme candidate à
la présidence de cette république
d'homme c'est légal et pourtant cela
shop cela paraît étrange même aux hommes
de gauche et cela doit l'être puisque je
suis la seule certes les grands partis
se disent tous partisans de l'égalité
des hommes et des femmes et ils n'en
finissent pas de voter et de re voter
des lois sur cette égalité mais quand il
s'agit de donner des responsabilités
quand il s'agit de commandes et de
diriger alors tous ces hommes là
considère que cela doit rester une
affaire d'hommes bien sûr parmi eux
personne n'ose dire que les femmes ne
sont pas capables d'exercer telle ou
telle fonction
mais dans les faits quelle place ont-ils
aux femmes sur plusieurs centaines de
ministres qui se sont succédé depuis 30
ans seulement deux femmes
huit femmes aujourd'hui au parlement sur
480 députés
et cela parce que tous les partis en
place tous les hommes politiques qu'ils
soient de droite ou de gauche ne mettent
pas leurs actes en accord avec leurs
paroles
là comme ailleurs ils mentent la preuve
c'est qu'aucun grand parti n'a juge est
une femme digne de leur présenter à ces
élections à lusine au bureau dans les
services les femmes n'ont que des
emplois subalternes
alors que les hommes sont en majorité
des cadres
l'immense majorité des femmes qui
travaillent sont commandés par des
hommes ont bien sûr on nous parle à la
radio et à l'école de la dignité d'être
mère et de l'importance du rôle de la
mère dans la famille dans la société
mais toutes les femmes qui travaillent
et qui ont dû demander à leur chef
une autorisation d'absence pour soigner
un enfant malade savent parfaitement
quel rebuffade
et quelle réflexion elles doivent
essuyer voilà la réalité et il faut la
dire les femmes c'est à dire la moitié
de la population de ce pays n'ont pas
des salaires égaux à ceux des hommes non
pas des post ego non pas des droits
égaux
ceux des hommes elles sont considérées
comme des citoyens de seconde zone et
traités comme tels ce sont des colonisés
des étrangères dans leur propre pays
votre société messieurs les politiciens
n'est pas sorti de la barbarie et c'est
vous qui lui maintenait y compris vous
sommes de gauche car n'oublions pas que
même le front populaire en 1936 n'avait
pas donné le droit de vote aux femmes
dans ce pays
il a fallu attendre la fin de la guerre
1945 pour que ce soit octroyée aux
femmes le droit de vote
et voilà qui montre d'ailleurs les
limites du bulletin de vote pour changer
notre sort car ce n'est pas parce que
les femmes ont le droit de vote
aujourd'hui que ce ne sont pas toujours
les hommes qui décident pour l y compris
en ce qui nous concerne nous directement
les femmes c'est une assemblée d'hommes
qui discute depuis des mois voire depuis
des années de savoir si les femmes ont
le droit d'interrompre ou pas une
grossesse non désirée eux parle de
morale de liberté de droits mais tolère
avec cynisme
l'inégalité flagrante systématique
inique dont les femmes sont victimes
alors comme l'on dit des centaines de
milliers de femmes en signant une
pétition récente
je ne suis pas un homme politique je ne
suis pas médecin je ne suis pas juriste
je suis une femme et j'exige le droit de
décider moi même si je dois ou pas avoir
des enfants et combien
et pour que ces politiciens acceptent
aujourd'hui avec combien de réticences
et de dérobade de discuter de modifier
la loi
il a fallu que des femmes courageuses
disent publiquement
oui j'ai avorté il a fallu que des
médecins hommes et femmes bravent la loi
et l'autorité judiciaire en proclamant
oui j'ai pratiqué des avortements
il a fallu que secret le mouvement pour
la liberté de l'avortement et de la
contraception le black et tous ceux qui
participent à ce combat ne sont pas
prêts à laisser l'assemblée nationale
décide des sols et à s'incliner devant
ses décisions
car les bourgeois qui se disent
partisans de la libéralisation de la loi
sur l'avortement et ceux qui en sont pas
devez resserre partage en fait la même
hypocrisie fondamental car le problème
le problème se posait aussi avec la même
acuité
monsieur mitterrand quand vous étiez
garde des sceaux ministre
en 1956 il faut que ces choses-là soit
dit
car il n'y a aucune femme dans ce pays
qu'elle soit bourgeoise ouvrière qui
n'ait été un jour ou l'autre confrontés
avec le problème d'une grossesse non
désirée et il n'y a aucune femme qui n'a
senti alors toute la détresse de sa
situation et qu'ils ne se soient
révoltés
comme contre une législation rétrograde
et hypocrite
elles ont alors réagi selon leur moral
et surtout selon leurs moyens mais tout
en ont été profondément marquées pour
toutes les femmes de ce pays
je réclame le droit à la contraception
ainsi que le droit car c'est un droit
d'interrompre une grossesse non désirée
en bénéficiant de toutes les garanties
médicales pour les socialistes
révolutionnaires l'égalité de l'homme et
de la femme n'est pas un droit c'est un
fait
si la femme occupe aujourd'hui une
situation inférieure à celle de l'homme
ce n'est pas dû à son manque de
capacités qui n'existe que dans la tête
des réactionnaires c'est parce que nous
vivons dans une société d'exploitation
une société qui repose sur la justice et
sur l'inégalité et les femmes toutes les
femmes y compris celle de la bourgeoisie
sont victimes de cette société
d'exploitation
bien sûr certaines ont des cages dorées
mais ce sont des cages quand même il
suffit de voir avec quelle impudence
en cette période d'élections tous
ministre pousse en avant leurs femmes ou
leurs filles comme ils exhibent leur
propriété ou leur titre et s'il y a des
femmes à qui s'appelait et bien tant pis
pour elle ce n'est pas elle que je
m'adresse
mais à toutes celles qui aspirent à être
reconnus comme des êtres humains à part
entière
et si des femmes de la bourgeoisie ne
vote pas pour moi parce que je suis une
militante d'extrême gauche cela ne me
gêne pas les ailes ont tort car elles
ont le choix entre leur conscience de
classe et leur conscience d'être humain
car c'est précisément parce que
j'appartiens à un mouvement
révolutionnaire que je suis là ce soir
et que je peux parler pour toutes les
femmes
ce n'est pas la seule raison pour
laquelle je me présente mais c'en est
une importante
je parlerai des autres dans mes
prochaines interventions et si je suis
la seule candidate féminine
ce n'est pas hasard et toutes les femmes
qui en sont conscientes doivent le mark
et le 5 mai en votant pour ma
candidature
[Musique]